With the UMG overview and Blueprint overview now out of the way, we are ready to get started
with our workshop.
Now our workshop is going to have the following goals.
It is to create a simple driving game, implement a game time limit, build a reusable
pickup object, and then create UMG display and menus.
So to do this, what we're first going to do is we are going to select from the
Unreal Project browser, select the games template, and we're going to select vehicle.
Make sure the variant is set to none, and then we can do something like Blueprint UMI UMG.
Let's go ahead and just pop over here.
So again, we're coming to our games project here, vehicle, no variant, and we're just
going to call this like BP UI UMG.
There we go.
And then I'm going to hit create to create this.
And once that gets created, the first thing that we're going to do is we're going to
go to our vehicle template blueprints and we're going to look for this BP GM vehicle
base.
This is going to, the GM stands for game mode, and we always want to make sure that
whenever we are building stuff, we're building it in the right area.
So game modes are rules that your game will follow.
So if we were building a tag, we would put the rules for tag inside of our game
mode.
So for us, what we're going to be doing is once we open up this game mode, we're
going to be using this to build our countdown timer.
And this is just good blueprint usage.
So let me pull our project over here.
So again, here's our project.
So it should be something like this where we press play.
We've got a car, it's going to go around the circle.
So that's fantastic.
We're going to come up to our content browser.
So I hit control space to bring that up and go to our vehicle template blueprint.
And we want our BP GM vehicle basic.
Now when that opens up, we aren't actually going to see anything.
We're just going to see our game session and things like that.
What we want to do here is we want to open in full blueprint editor.
And what that's going to do is that's going to turn that from a data only blueprint
into a blueprint that we can edit.
Now with that blueprint editable, we are going to create a timer.
So what we're going to do is we're going to add an event begin play node.
So when we start our game, we're going to first create a timer, and we're going to set
it to a time of one second.
And we're going to have this loop.
This is basically going to be creating our looping timer.
So as it goes from whatever 10 down to zero, this is going to help do that.
So let's pop back over here to the editor now.
So again, we're going to right click and we're going to look for event begin.
And we want this event begin play, event begin play.
And when we do that, actually, I'm not going to pull off that just yet because I'm going
to click in here and look for set timer by and we want this set timer by event.
Now we're going to connect these two together.
And with the time, we're going to set this to one.
And we're going to keep this on looping.
Now the next thing that we need to do is we need to make a custom event.
So we're going to look for a custom and then there's our add custom event.
And we're going to call it countdown.
I'm going to take that and bring that right over here.
Now if we were to do something like this, do a print string, and we go compile and save,
we should get something.
And yeah, see it's saying hello there.
So that's definitely working.
And we can see here, just to verify, if we go here to this game vehicle spawn, we
should see this counting down.
So every second, just printing out hello.
So that's what we should be having right there.
We can see that working.
So that's good start for us.
So I'm going to go ahead and delete that because it is not needed.
But the next thing that we're going to do here is we are going to create a new variable
called time remaining.
We're going to set it to an integer.
The reason we set it to an integer is because our time is going to be one, two, three.
We're not necessarily going to have 30.5 seconds or 30.26 seconds.
So anywhere where we know that we're going to be using integers versus floats, we want
to make sure that we make a variable type that will work with that data appropriately.
So you maybe you're used to just using all floats.
That's not the best thing to do.
The best thing in our case to do is to make that an integer because again, we know
that we're not going to have any half seconds or quarter seconds.
It's going to be 10 seconds or 15 seconds.
So let's go over to our editor.
Now we're going to come over to our variables, we're going to add a new one and we're going
to call it time remaining and we are going to set it to an integer.
There we go.
And let's just compile this and save.
Now every time we add a variable, we always need to compile in order to give that variable
a default value.
So there we go.
We're going to set this to 10 and let's just compile and save that again.
So what we're going to do next is we're going to pull in that time remaining and
then we're going to use this integer decrement and basically we're going to check to see
when the time remaining is less than zero, we're going to do something.
If it's not less than zero, we're going to continue to do what we're doing right
now, which is nothing.
So let's go ahead and set this up.
So we're going to come over here and then we're going to take our time remaining and
we're going to left click and drag and we're going to go get time remaining and
then we're going to pull off of this countdown custom event and we're going to go minus minus
and this is going to get our, we have a float here, but we want the integer so we're going
to say decrement int and then we're going to plug our two like so.
Then what we're going to do is we're going to pull off of our result here and we're
going to look for less than and then last we're going to get a branch.
Now we can add this branch a couple of different ways.
We can pull out of here and look for a branch.
There's the branch right there.
Or if you want, you can hold down the B key and you will add a branch as well.
That's usually the way that I add branches by holding down the B key.
So that is going to make up the first part of this.
And now what we're going to do in the next section is we're going to take a look
at blueprint interfaces as they are a great way to cheaply and efficiently send data
back and forth between multiple blueprints.